- Oh, why she gotta ask
question like this, hold up!
- Oh.
- Oh, gosh.
- Woof, okay.
- I had a bad childhood, so that's a lot.
(person laughs)
(calm piano music)
- I kinda wish I never heard
what people think about me,
because it really changes
my perspective on myself
and it kinda drags my confidence down.
A lotta people talk about
my weight or how I look,
and honestly, I feel like if
people kept their opinions
to themselves, that would
be a lot more helpful,
but people are just opinionated I guess.
- When I was five years
old, my mom told me I was
going to die, and I
remember being very shocked,
and I really got upset,
because it was the first time
that I realized I was going to die.
- When my doctor told me I
had stage two lung cancer,
that would probably be
one of the big ones, yeah.
This was in October of last year.
I'm in college, so I went
to my local wellness center
(person laughs)
when I started coughing
up blood, actually,
and then they referred me to a doctor
who then diagnosed me,
and I remember walking in,
and it was kind of your classic, like,
doctor on one side, you
sit on the other side
and he looks all somber, and he's like,
you have cancer, and then you're like, .
(person laughing)
And so, I kind of went into shock.
I had taken public
transportation to the doctor
so I took public transportation back
and I was just like, in
my seat just zoning out,
and then I remember getting back,
calling my boyfriend at the time,
telling him the news and just
sitting there in silence,
and then after that call
ended I just burst into tears,
and I was like, well, what do I do now?
I had so many plans, and now I don't know
if I'll even be here to do them.
I remember going back
into my dorm and having
to tell my suite mates and
having to comfort them.
(person laughing)
And then going back into
my own room and just
trying to decide how to
reprioritize my life.
I think that was the hardest part.
My dad had non-small cell lung cancer,
and I had small cell lung cancer.
So we thought maybe it might be genetics,
but it wasn't connected.
I don't smoke, I'm very young,
(person laughing)
so we still don't know.
My family encouraged me
to drop out of school,
which I refused to do, 'cause
it's really important to me
that I graduate in four
years, so I stayed in school,
and then I think it was
four or five months later,
I beat cancer, technically,
finished my semester,
didn't fail any classes, which was good,
and I've been in remission ever since,
so hopefully I never
have to hear that again.
That was around my birthday too, actually,
my 20th birthday, it
was like a week before.
It's like, this is the
best birthday present
I've ever gotten.
Just being able to go back and tell people
that they didn't have to
worry about me any more,
at least for now, that was incredible.
It was freedom, it was a lot of freedom,
to not be scared, to
pursue what I wanted to do.
- My childhood best friend
passed away of cancer
when he was just 21 or 22,
and for a very long time
was very passionate about
being an airline pilot,
and he was probably one of the most,
was a kind of prodigy, so he was able
to go through flight
school really quickly,
and he was known as the baby
pilot because he was able
to become an airline pilot so young
and he had such a baby face
that people could not believe
that he was already an airline pilot.
But then very soon after that,
he was not even diagnosed,
he just was walking,
I think, in Dubai or Abu
Dhabi on a flight trip,
and he just collapsed on the floor,
and it turned out that he had like,
a cancer grew in his back
and it was just terminal.
Actually has changed a little bit the
way I choose my career.
Now I work in, the last
two company I've worked in
was all related with cancer,
and I realized that cancer
is a common thing that
maybe one of three people
in your life will probably
suffer in their lifetime,
and so I work on the
early cancer detection.
There have been so many improvements
that within our generation,
I think it will be a disease
that I think we could eradicate
if we put the right people
and the right money towards it.
- [Interviewer] Can you
describe your best friend
to us the best you can?
- Yeah, he was just like
a bubbly, happy guy,
just always in a good
mood and very positive.
Maybe not the most extroverted,
but very passionate.
I feel like I've found my
passion maybe later in life,
but he knew from the beginning
that he wanted to fly planes.
I think it's always
amazing to see people have
such conviction in what they
want to do and pursue that
and make it happen and never give up
on their childhood dreams.
Your childhood dream is
like, you know, you listen
less to your brain or to your mind
but you listen to your heart,
and often times you get older,
you listen more to your mind
and rationalize yourself
out of things that you
know is right for you,
but you just can't lose track of that,
and I think he never lost
track of what his passion
of what he wanted as a kid and did it.
Although he didn't live very long,
I think a life worth living is
not counted in years, right,
it's more about what
you do, what you become.
It doesn't matter how short it is.
I think his life was
worth every second of it,
and made it count.
- I wish I would have never heard
or at least read the suicide notes
of a boy in my class about
the way our school treated him
and why he did what he did.
He just said that at least like
the neighborhood we lived in
and the community we lived in
put too much pressure on kids
to go to the right school,
to go in the same path way,
to go to college after high school,
and how none of the teachers supported him
and none of the adults who had authority
would listen to him, but
it's really caused change
in my school, which is a positive result,
but I didn't really wanna know that kids
were going through something like that.
It's kind of dark.
- I wish I had never heard that
my friends sometimes use me.
- Racism.
All my life I've heard about racism,
I've learned about it, I've studied it.
It was like, kinda unique topic to me,
'cause I never understood why
other people would look at
other people a certain way
and try to control them just because they
were a different color than they were,
but everyone's a person,
like you have an eyes,
nose, teeth, ears, a heart,
and everyone should be the same.
I think that everyone's equal,
and you're not higher than anyone else.
- One thing, 'cause we were
talking about it this morning,
is I wish I never heard
that the devil was real,
or that, like, anything
about the devil as a child.
- I wish,
(sucks teeth)
I wish I'd never heard
about how meat was made,
or is made.
(people laughing)
Because I like to eat meat, but I also
don't wanna add to animal
cruelty, but it's so good.
- I wished I never heard
that Santa was real,
because since I was
little, I got two things.
One thing, my house
doesn't have a chimney,
(child giggles)
and two things, how does one man know
when seven billion people are sleeping?
(child giggles)
Like, that makes no sense,
and I'm a very logical person.
But I don't want my little
brother to be discouraged
or anything, so I'm just gonna
act like he's real, you know?
(boy laughing)
(calm piano music)
- Rude words.
- [Interviewer] Do you have
any specific ones in mind?
- No.
And if I had, I wouldn't say them.
(person laughing)
- Uh, you might wanna get tested.
(people laughing)
- Probably that you're
not college material.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you
remember who told you that?
- My grandmother.
I, personally, think that
everybody's college material,
and it's just, coming from lower class,
it's hard to, obviously I'm
not going to go to Harvard.
Who goes to Harvard?
Rich people, not me!
She tells the same thing to my sister.
She tells me, like, your
sister's not college material,
and I'm like, you can't
say that to someone,
'cause it's gonna discourage
them from going to college.
I'm already going to graduate
with my bachelor's debt-free,
and I've traveled the world,
and so anybody can do it.
It really discourages someone to say that,
and I wanna go get my PhD, and
I wanna do all these things,
but I don't know, it always kinda sticks
in the back of my mind, like,
you're not college material,
you're not gonna get
there, but like, I am.
- I wish I'd never heard
the term fake news.
Because I feel like the
people who work so hard,
go to college, they try
to be so fair and balanced
in their reporting, it's their life.
And ever since this
fake news rumor started,
nobody has a belief
anymore, in institutions,
in the news media, in their leaders,
and so the whole belief system is eroded
and that's what I wish I had never heard.
- We don't have enough money.
I'm a teacher and I'm from Arizona,
and legislators are always
saying they don't have
enough money to fund our education system,
and as a result our children
are going to be illiterate.
The teachers don't stay more than a year
and they all go, and I,
well, they have enough money.
They're not using it to take care
of what needs to be taken care of.
They put in the rainy day
fund, but it's already rainy.
- I wish I hadn't heard my dad, like,
talk about how much he cheated on my mom.
I don't know, 'cause like
I'd saw him differently
every since then.
- I wish I never had all this story
of so many religions in this world,
because I don't believe in religions.
I believe there is one God,
but I don't believe in the religions.
Religions separate
brothers, sisters, friends,
create trouble to others, but
if you go through all of them
which have been in all of them,
everybody say God is good.
So there's only one God.
There is not religions.
That's my own belief today.
- My answer kind of answers the question,
but it's a bit of a variety.
It's more of one thing
that I've heard repeatedly
that I would like to have not heard,
so hopefully that counts.
Something that I wouldn't
have liked to hear
is anytime my dad kind of yells at my mom
in a negative way or
if she makes a mistake
or if she slips up anywhere,
even though she's just tryin'a
do the right thing, my dad
kinda gets angry at her.
So I think anytime that's happened,
I would have enjoyed
not being part of that.
I feel like a terrible bystander
just watching something bad happen,
like I love my mom, I love my dad.
My dad isn't a bad person by any means.
He's actually a great
person, so is my mom.
She just has good intentions,
and sometimes the execution
doesn't work out well,
which is just unfortunate
and I think we all have
that so empathy where
if you see someone trying really hard
but they don't quite
achieve whatever it is
that they're tryin' to do, that
you just feel bad for them,
because you tell everyone oh, if you try,
as long as you're trying,
everything's fine,
but there's obviously
incidents where you're trying
and things don't work
out, and that really sucks
and there's nothing you can
do about it, like, you know.
- I think that's a hard
question for me specifically,
because with the way my personality is,
I would always rather
know, even if it hurts.
Recently, maybe a month or two ago,
I learned that my dad has cancer.
And he didn't tell me.
I learned from an ex, actually,
and my dad still hasn't told me about it,
and I'm, I mean, I don't know
if he's ever gonna tell me
or if I'll learn at his
funeral, but I'm glad I know.
I'm glad it's not gonna come out
of nowhere and blindside me.
Life hurts and like,
sometimes it hurts to be alive
and sometimes it hurts to get bad news
and sometimes, like sometimes things are .
Like sometimes everything
is just gonna be .
But you can't come to terms
with something you don't know about.
(calm piano music)
- Hey guys, thanks for
watching another episode.
If you haven't subscribed
to my channel yet,
please make sure to hit
the subscribe button
and the little bell next to
it so you'll get notified
every time I put up a new episode
and if you have some
friends that you think
might also like the
episodes, it would mean a lot
if you shared my episodes
with them as well,
if you want.
I think that's pretty much it.
Thank you guys again, and
I'll see you next week.